[MUSIC]
The algorithms that allow us to
reveal your intimate traits and
psychological profile, one of the powerful
application of such algorithms,
is to target you with marketing messages
and tailor those messages to make
them most interesting and
most relevant to you as an individual.
Now, one of the types of
marketing that is heavily
employing such approaches
is political marketing.
And in fact, Barack Obama was one of
the first politicians that started
using algorithms of this
kind on a massive scale.
And now, it's a fact
of life that politicians will use
micro-targeting of their political
messages to reach out to the voters.
Naturally, people are concerned about it.
But my personal opinion is that
people are concerned about the wrong
part of the story here.
So just the sheer fact that you can
target people with relevant messages,
messages that are matched to
their interests, fears, dreams,
personalities, and so on,
is a very good thing.
That is an equivalent of a politician
coming to your household,
taking time to get to know each one
of the members of your household.
And then trying to explain to them,
hey, you see my program, this part
of my program or that part of my program,
will help you to realize your dreams,
and prevent the bad things that you fear
from happening, which is an amazing thing.
It keeps the message
more relevant to people.
It keeps people more
interested in the message.
And it also makes people more competent
to judge the quality of such message.
Which is great for democratic process.
We're having more engaged,
more interested voters that
are being talked to about things that
are important and relevant to them.
So just great news for democracy.
I believe.
Also, it has also many other consequences
that are very often overlooked.
If I can target voters with my
message in an accurate way,
I basically can stop broadcasting,
just generate
messages using TVs, and
expensive ads in newspapers.
Which basically means that political
dialogue between politicians and
voters became much cheaper.
I can reach the voters
using way cheaper means,
such as Facebook marketing targeting,
or adverts, or
Tweets and adverts, or
adverts sending other environments.
Which, again,
has an amazing effect of decreasing
the reliance of politicians on big money.
If you can be talking to voters
at a fraction of a cost that you
needed 10 or 20 years ago, it means that
you also have much less debts to pay
to big industry and other potentially
very influential players on the market.
So it's great news, and
we had at least two big examples of
that happening in recent election.
We had Bernie Sanders and Donald Trump who
both were not the part of establishment.
They both didn't have much
experience in politics,
really, or kind of running for
President politics.
And also they have had very small
funds compared with funds that
some other mainstream politicians
like Jeb Bush or Hillary Clinton had.
And yet, they were able to
energize great numbers of voters,
and in the case of one of them,
win the election, right?
Another, I think, consequence
of micro-targeting in political
messaging that people are often
overlooking is that because you are not
limited to broadcasting generic messages,
and
you can now micro-target messages to make
them interesting and relevant to people.
What happens is that now it makes sense
to reach out to the voters that were
previously excluded from
the political dialog.
Because maybe we didn't make an economic
sense to try to target them with
your broadcasted message.
And again, we can see that with
both Trump and Sanders energizing
types of electorate that was
not really energized before.
The larger the fraction of the society
that we bring in to the political process,
the better for democracy.
Now, having said that, you can use the
very same political message targeting to,
let's say, discourage people from voting.
And we have seen this in
last selection as well,
where you could see very well targeted
messages aimed at the electorate
of your opponent to try to discourage
them from casting the vote.
And now,
this is an awful use of such technology.
But again, instead of focusing on
trying to blame the technology for
this thing happening, we should rather
kind of, technology's just a medium here.
We should just focus on
the phenomenon itself.
We should perhaps start discussing
whether it's okay to allow for
negative marketing in politics.
And by the way, there are countries,
the free Western democracies
where negative marketing in politics is
basically not acceptable or even illegal.
[MUSIC]
Human history is a history
of great change, full stop.
We were always living
through great changes.
It's just that recently,
the speed of progress has accelerated.
So we have a great change every
couple months, or every couple years.
But we also have a lot of evidence
from the history showing that humanity
basically adjusts their behavior,
and figures out how to
avoid the downsides, and employ
the upsides of a given great change.
And starting from agriculture
through industrial revolution.
And then, something perhaps
more relevant to the subject of
this conversation which is
explosion of marketing.
When you first had
billboards on the roads, or
first large format ads in newspapers,
people were also discussing it.
It was seen as the end of
the world as we know it, and
now everyone will be manipulated.
And the world will be just handed over
to marketers who'd be just running it.
And we kind of know that
is just did not happen.
Partly, because people developed
an immune system, immunity to those ads.
And now, l think that the same will
happen with digital marketing.
You probably already stopped
noticing adverts on the websites,
your brain learned it's
just not worth looking at.
Not to mention,
that now we have technology, ad blockers,
that just basically explicitly remove
those ads from your online experience.
Now obviously, the progress,
it's a never ending race.
So once we learn how to avoid being
swayed too much by online ads,
the companies are just developing new
ways of manipulating or influencing us.
And a good example is related to
how news feed on Facebook works.
So people don't realize that when they see
a story that is shared by their friend,
the fact that they see a story is a
product of both friends sharing the story.
But also, the company behind the story,
the outlets behind the story
paying Facebook money for
this given story being shown
on your news feed, right?
So people don't really realize,
people think,
it's just my friend sharing a story.
And what I can see here on my news feed
is a representative representation of
what my friends are talking about.
In fact, it's not.
It's a product of what your friends are
talking about and how much money a given
company behind a given story was
willing to pay Facebook to promote it.
And I think that people don't
realize it now, but with time,
we'll just adjust our
perception to this phenomenon,
as we adjusted our perception
to phenomena of the past.
[MUSIC]